samsung a présenté il ya quelques jours
lors de sa conférence des développeurs
ce qui va être le galaxy fold deuxième
version alors déjà eu la version en
cette année qui a été montrées lundi
lors de cette même conférence avait été
montrée lumière coupé smartphone ouvert
vous voyez absolument rien à cette fois
ci ils ont joué le jeu un petit peu
différemment ils ont pas senti de
smartphones il vous en montrer une
illustration
un croquis ce à quoi pourrait ressembler
le smartphone attention il est bien
écrit en bas sont des images pour
l'illustration la version finale
pourrait être légèrement différente
évidemment ils font pas tout vous
révéler maintenant ils vont pas tout
nous dire mais en tout cas ce qu'il
montre c'est assez intéressant
[Musique]
il ya déjà quelques mois vous avez fait
une vidéo dans lequel je vous disais qu
effectivement en 2020 samsung allait
sortir différents smartphones pliable
salle dessous devrait proposer en 2020
pas un nouveau galaxy fold mais
carrément une gamme des galaxies folle
en fait samsung mise sur l'avenir sur
les smartphones pliable et non pas juste
fait un one shot sur un âne en se disant
tiens on fait un galaxy fold et puis
s'il marche pas il y en aura pas d'autre
il était évident que ce galaxy fold avec
un prix à plus de 1000 euros elle est
compliquée à commercialiser ils ont
plutôt tâter le marché envoie là on
innove
voilà ce qu'on sait faire on est le
premier à sortir et maintenant on va
pouvoir commencer à démocratiser tout ça
et c'est justement là où l'étape 2
arrive la démocratisation c'est à dire
la pollution à plus grande échelle donc
on devrait avoir l année prochaine les
galaxies folle à différents prix doit
toujours le gros plat chip le court au
galaxy folk coûte bien cher avec toutes
les innovations
nous aurons aussi des galaxies fois
probablement un peu moins cher alors
maintenant la question qui se pose et
c'est justement ce que vous montrez dans
cette vidéo ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'en fait on avait ce galaxy
folle qui se plie comme l'espèce de
livres vous avez votre petit écran de 4
pouces et quelques jeux d'ouvriers vous
aviez un très grand écran
justement nous ont montré on va le faire
mais on va le faire aussi différemment
vous avez un grand smartphone et là vous
le replier comme un smartphone à clapet
alors tout au final est assez
intéressant parce que ça pousse à la
réflexion c'est à dire que lorsque vous
avez votre grand smartphone le galaxy
folk tel qu'on le connaît tel qu'il a
été présenté
lorsqu'il est fermé vous avez un écran
de notification qui vous permet de voir
vos notifications vos sms qui vous
appelle quelques petites choses ne va
pas bien loin le bonheur se passe à
l'intérieur vous l'ouvrez là ça devient
intéressant c'est à dire que par rapport
à un smartphone classique on va venir
agrandir la surface sur laquelle on
pouvait revenir travailler la surface de
visionnage d'être vraiment a grandi donc
le smartphone pliable dans ce cas là va
servir à voir l'écran beaucoup plus
grands on se rapproche d'une tablette
même si l'on n'y est pas c'est donc
filer au scotch galaxie folle il vient
se plier pouvoir se ranger dans une
poche
l'idc on a grandi avec ce qu'ils nous
ont montré justement lors de la
conférence développeurs c'est qu'on a un
galaxy folle qui ne sert pas cette fois
ci à agrandir mais qui sert justement à
avoir la forme qu'à la taille
sensiblement d'un smartphone classique
probablement du 6 7 pouces de diagonale
d'ailleurs on devrait avoir un ratio
intéressant probable
1,22 ne vienne quelque chose comme ça
parce qu'on a quand même qu'il est
relativement lent ont nourri le
probablement ce qu'on a sur un
smartphone potentiellement classique
dans les dimensions de 2019 c'est à dire
de très grands écrans
hélas pour coup on va pas venir
augmenter la surface de l'écran non on
vient gagner de la place on vient le
compact et pour ranger c'est à dire
qu'on peut effectivement le var dans les
deux sens sont agrandies de l'écran soit
un compact c'est assez mal être leur
poids qui était fait aux galaxies fold
version 1 c'est que même une fois pliée
il est épais il est grand il prend la
place pour le mettre dans un jean louis
ses moyens pratiques dans un sac
pourquoi pas mais il est quand même
assez grande
là on va avoir un smartphone un peu plus
compact qui restera quand même un peu
épais parce que bien évidemment on a les
deux parties qui se remplit l'une sans
l'autre mais en tout cas qui serait
beaucoup moins grand donc plus facile à
glisser dans une poche ou dans un sac à
main en gardant un form factor de
smartphones petit peu standard via les
écrans pliables peuvent s'utiliser de
différentes manières et avec différents
usa qu'est ce qui est très intéressant
si on va creuser un peu plus loin et se
regardent justement ce que nous a
montrée samsung au travers de son
croquis son esquisse sa création même si
c'est pas une version définitive est
bien c'est que en haut vous avez un
petit trou alors je ne pense pas que le
smartphone de l'année prochaine et le
petit trou petit poisson comment la sur
le galaxy s 10 de cette année je pense
qu'en 2020 va arriver avec les nouveaux
galaxy s des appareils photos
complètement intégrée sous l'écran 500
en tout cas aller dans le bon sens ce
qui serait intéressant
on pourrait donc avoir de système un peu
la veille saïdi pour déverrouiller avec
de la tra rouge planqué dessous plus
d'encoches pas de points sont pas de
bulle et ça serait vraiment bien ils
n'ont pas montré aujourd'hui pour dire
effectivement vous aurez petite caméra
de cette fille mais on a dix-sept
caméras de cette fille elle sera gommée
elle sera caché sous l'écran on verra ça
l'année prochaine en 2020 d'ailleurs
j'invite à vous abonner
ce n'est pas déjà fait comme ça on verra
ça directement sans doute à ses premiers
trucs et deuxième pause dans montre un
visage qui est très intéressant c'est
que lorsque le smartphone vous le client
à moitié ou le piller à 90° une partie
poser une partie pliée
eh bien il va y avoir une adaptation du
point de vue de l' os on sera bien
évidemment sur un nuage
deux là dessus sur un android disent ce
qu'ils nous montrent c'est qu'on en
train de filmer on voit bien ça tourne
ça veut donc dire que sur la partie
haute
oddo vous allez avoir vos caméras je
pense qu'on aura au moins un minima un
triple module photo comme ce qu'on a sur
les galaxy s 10 et ce qui est très mal
derrière ça c'est que qui dit module
photo là des pouvoirs le poser comme ça
de la save you come espèce de petit
trépied donc intéressant lorsque vous
voulez vous même venir vous filmez et on
peut même venir imaginer qu'une fable
smartphone plier sur le dessus vous
allez avoir un petit écran de
notification et ce petit écran de
notification vous servir et deux
moniteurs à ce moment là puisque votre
smartphone je ne sais pas ce que je peux
vous prendre pour vous montrer ça on va
prendre terrasse espèce de truc là ça
c'est la taille du smartphone tout ce
qui est en dessous hop on ne le voit pas
je le vis dans ma manche je le plante
donc ça c'est notre smartphone je sais
ça ne ressemble pas du tout à un
smartphone vous allez venir le plier
comme ça là vous avez l'écran de
notification et lorsque vous le poser à
plat comme ça là vous avez vos caméras
vos écrans notification donc vous pouvez
à la fois vous voir vous avez les
caméras là et ça pour les blogueurs pour
les créateurs de contenu c'est
extrêmement intéressant
ça permettrait effectivement de pouvoir
filmer c'est évident comme il le montre
en tout cas par a montré par hasard si
vous voulez le fait de pouvoir l'adapter
le plier et qu'on est en train de filmer
loes qui s'adapte c'est bien évidemment
une caméra et je vois pas pourquoi on
n'aurait pas un petit écran de
notification donc j'imagine que les
caméras seront posées probablement à
l'horizontale et pas à la verticale donc
j'imagine pourquoi pas des caméras à
l'horizontale un écran notification
dessous ça pourrait être vraiment
intéressant et montre et d'autres usages
en tant qu intéressant c'est que votre
smartphone une fois grand verdun
évidemment de vous aurez un très grand
écran plus grand que ce qu'on a
actuellement sur les smartphones donc on
pourra utiliser pour faire du multitâche
c'est aussi assez prometteur pour
augmenter la productivité bien
évidemment lorsque vous allez le tourner
on va pouvoir regarder du contenu
multimédia l'or spot un peu bizarre
sectionnés sur un écran format 22 9e et
bien tout ce qu'ils essayent neuvième
pour le coup vous allez venir rouler
dedans mais vous allez perdre beaucoup
de contenu vodka manière ça pourrait
être intégrée d'un point de vue logiciel
pour te soit réellement intéressant
effectivement le format 21/9 c'est
format cinémascope il existe des vidéos
sur youtube ou déviés sur netflix aux 21
9e mais la plupart où sont tournées soit
en 16 9e soit on hésite 9e donc sur un
écran 22 9e
j'ai peur que ce soit un petit peu moyen
à voir également comment les éditeurs
pourront venir adapter leur jeu
parce que lorsque vous jouez un format
epub view ce que vous voulez sur l'écran
très long faut voir aussi comment ça
peut être adaptée ça pour moi c'est
obligatoire qu'on a un écran
notification extérieur je peux pas
imaginer qu'on n'ait pas simplement
parce que une fois votre smartphone
replié
quelqu'un va vous téléphoner imaginez
vous et votre smartphone il est plié le
téléphone sonne
vous prenez votre smartphone et là vous
voyez pas ça me paraîtrait quand même
relativement bizarre qu'il faudrait
l'ouvrir voir à l'intérieur
appuyer sur l'écran tactile pour moi y
aurait trop d'étapes et ça pourrait pas
fonctionner ce qui par contre a
contrario fonctionnerait dire que vos
smartphones est posée il est fermé
vous avez votre écran de notification le
téléphone sonne
ok qui m'appelle je prends mon téléphone
je vois le nom la photo comme ce soit et
là un petit peu à l'ancienne je prends
mon smartphone et je l'ouvré dès lors
que je loue ça décroche c'est
obligatoire ça se passera sur ce genre
de format j'imagine pas acheter des
étapes contraignantes
on ouvre on voit on a pu pour décrocher
on perd du temps on a le smartphone il
est là il est posé sur une table
je vois directement qui est en train de
m'appeler je le prends je lève je
décroche de la même manière que je veut
raccrocher je me replie ça accroche et
je le pose c'est tout bête tout simple
c'est très logique ça existait avant et
je vois pas comment pas voir un
smartphone style smartphone à clapet et
ne pas adapter ça comme ça qu'on peut
pousser la réduction se disant tiens va
du coup ce nous font un galaxy folle
comme ça qui se plie comme un smartphone
à clapet que va-t-il advenir du form
factor du galaxy foot elle qui les
présentent actuellement je pense
effectivement samsung va proposer
différents form factor puisqu'on a des
écrans qui se plie il faut les utiliser
comme ils peuvent être utilisés
vous auriez donc un galaxy folle comme
on l'a connu aujourd'hui sur les passe
temps d'armer telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui qui sera amélioré mon avis
en 2020 probablement différentes
versions une version un peu plus light
est une version premium
j'imagine que cette grosse encoches
intérieure va disparaître puisqu'il
pourrait potentiellement intégrer les
caméras sous l'écran comme je vous l'aï
dit tout à l'heure
donc autant l'intégrer à l'intérieur
vous aurez donc un grand écran utile
toujours un écran notification en avant
mais qui serait peut-être peut-être un
peu plus grands un smartphone qui je
l'espère sera plus fins et un trépas
lien pas ce problème de ce parti d'un
petit peu gros pour vous glisser dans
votre poche qui déforme qui est pas très
très pratique
on aurait donc une gamme galaxy folle
qui s'étendrait et là ça commence à
devenir vraiment intéressant parce qu'on
arriverait enfin dans le smartphone
pliable plus destiné au grand public
avec le galaxy folle ça me saoule non
vraiment une nouvelle technologie voir
comment elles intégrées sont les
premiers à dégainer
mais c'est pas un smartphone qui
s'adresse à la grande majorité des
consommateurs plus de 1000 euros pour
smartphones moi je ne mets pas j'imagine
que vous êtes très nombreux et nombreux
à ne pas vouloir mettre cet argent là
elle là dedans on pourrait imaginer un
galaxy folle moins cher à voir cette
techno le produire en masse
mécaniquement ce serait baisser les prix
reste à voir comment est-ce qu'il est
réussir et à tirer les prix vers le bas
aussi en intégrant cette technologie
comme ça ça pourrait être intéressant je
pense qu'en 2020 va être l'année de la
démocratisation des smartphones qui
gagnent en 2020 d'ailleurs beaucoup de
choses intéressantes
l'arrivée de la singer dans beaucoup de
pays le déploiement dans les grandes
villes des smartphones qui iront plus
vite des smartphones plus compact des
smartphones qui se plieront je pense que
2020 va être une très bonne année dites
moi ce que vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire comment est-ce que vous
l'imaginez quels usages vous verriez sur
ce galaxy fold v2 à clapet et quels
usages variés sur le galaxy folle tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui corrigé améliorer
et à quel prix est ce que vous pourriez
lâcheté mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain bigouden